botar gente meu nome é gabriel guimarães
eu sou de vitória espírito santo eu
tenho 22 anos e eu estudo ciência da
computação economia
lá em harvard nos estados unidos hoje eu
queria começar uma brincadeirinha pra
fazer essa brincadeirinha preço de um
voluntário favor qualquer um da platéia
algum voluntário
vamos lá como é o nome armando sabe que
por favor
armando manteiga ou sonhos os
computadores então
primeiro a gente vai falar de pão com
manteiga é eu trabalho muito com o
computador a computador uma máquina e
você tem que dá instruções para essa
máquina todos mas funciona assim hoje em
dia e basicamente quem vai fazer aqui é
essa idéia de máquina como funcionará o
senhor dá instruções você vai dar as
instruções para fazer um pão com
manteiga
tá bom eu queria saber de todo mundo que
na platéia quem sabe que é um algoritmo
levanta a mão
bastante gente foi ó e quem sabe fazer
um pão com manteiga
mas gente ainda maravilha e do seguinte
eu sou uma máquina de fazer pão com
manteiga
a gente tem aqui de forma manteiga e
faca e eu quero que você me deu as
instruções
o pessoal da produção que comprou mas
acho que mantenha assim eu quero só que
você me deu as instruções passo a passo
de como fazer o nosso algoritmo de fazer
um pão com manteiga
o primeiro abriu o pacote abre o pacote
de bombons de pão
dessa maneira um pouco mais carinhoso
segundo instrução for abrir mais
calmamente mais tranquilamente em um
potinho de manteiga pouquinho de
manteiga
é um assassino potencial
certamente os confinados que em sua
maioria não pode ser sempre a mesma
coisa que a produção depois lembrar jean
todt um passo diz travar aquela faca lá
que você cometeu o crime ele pega uma
das fatias de pão que você conseguiu
manter em cima da mesa e começa a passar
manteiga no pão
muito obrigado uma salva de palmas
obrigado gente a idéia aqui acaba de
fazer um algoritmo e os humanos eles são
muito mais inteligência a gente fala pra
ela pra gente
as pessoas sabe do que está falando só
preocupam se entende muito fácil os
controles são muito mais burros e você
tem que ser muito mais muito mais
sistemático na hora de explicar
tem que pegar a faca como um direito e
rodar no sentido anti-horário 70 graus e
assim por diante
o mundo não vai entender na verdade na
verdade é isso que a gente fez aqui foi
a primeira aula de computação que
assiste razão da minha vida e quando
assistir isso mudou completamente a
minha vida um curso chamado se ft que o
curso introdutório de ciência da
computação a de harvard e eu tinha 16
anos e estava morando na alemanha na
época e eu achei o curso na internet
todas as dinâmicas de todas as idéias
grandiosas interessantes como o
algoritmo mostrar de forma tão simples
no dia a dia não só no computador mas o
dia a dia das pessoas
eu fiquei maravilhado eu estava no
ensino médio então os recursos na no
youtube
eu fiquei tão maravilhado com essas
idéias que eu mandei pra minha irmã está
sentada logo aqui e falei nossa é muito
legal eu quero muito fazer mais e mais
eu fiquei viciado negócio eu acabei
assistindo todas as aulas fazendo todos
os exercícios um por um em três semanas
e tinha acabado o curso de harvard dos
alunos de raiva e demorou quatro meses
para fazer tudo que eu tinha ficado tão
apaixonado por um preço o negócio mas aí
eu num
queria nem conseguia se eu quisesse
parar por ali é quando terminei o cpf
pela internet
eu pensei 'por ser é muito legal a gente
pudesse trazer essa experiência minha
experiência que eu tive para a gente no
brasil que o brasil tem tanta gente boa
que gosta dessas coisas que poderia
aprender muito com curso desses que eu
nunca tinha visto um curso nada parecido
com isso
e isso as pessoas não podem talvez o
caso do inglês também porque não
conhecem talvez que já pensam que
harvard uma coisa pra elas
então aquele dia eu mandei um e mail o
professor de harvard responsável pelo
curso perguntei eu sou um aluno de 16
anos gabriel guimarães
acabei de fazer os cursos têm muito eu
posso traduzir e discurso no brasil o
professor não sei nem se eu acredito
muito na época mas ele falou pode ter
problema nenhum e passou todo o material
e e eu fui tocando é foram umas 400
páginas de material aproximadamente que
traduzido em inglês para português
eu fiz um site onde os alunos pudessem
entrar nesse curso e fazer todos os
sexos problemas entregar receber todas
as notas e que eu queria na verdade da
experiência exatamente a experiência
tinha tido só que em português e foi
assim que surgiu c-50 ciência da
computação 50
eu acabei dando esse curso quando voltei
da alemanha na próxima semana é de
discurso pela primeira vez acabei dando
mais duas vezes depois por um total de
us 250 pessoas presenciais e o meu pai
que também está ali é ajudou a filmar
todas as aulas para os poder colocar a
internet sempre fez tudo de graça porque
o objetivo era sempre trazer computação
para mais e mais pessoas interessadas e
hoje em dia os 150 é um dos maiores
cursos de computação na internet e eu
tenho muita satisfação de olhar e ver
que tem gente não só do brasil mas de
angola e moçambique e portugal que estão
a prender o centro de computação usando
esse curso
continuando aí a minha jornada um pouco
ela cai entre a universidade de harvard
e quando eu entrei o professor me chamou
de vilã
ele tinha acompanhado a sua trajetória
no brasil ele me chamou pra ser monitor
do curso cef do original de rayfran foi
experiência muito legal que eu estava
trabalhando concurso de verdade
finalmente ir a primeira vez que um
calouro estava dando aula de tango da
monitoria na história desse curso em
árvore e foi muito legal e depois de
seis mil
ele ainda me fez uma proposta e fez
quase caí da cadeira que ele me chamou
para ser basicamente a pessoa que ia
liberar os recife inteiro lá em ordem de
época é um curso que atualmente o
software e hardware é o maior curso da
universidade com mais mil alunos
presenciais só em árvore tem o dinheiro
ontem ao dn e e é um dos maiores músicos
do mundo
para quem não sabe aquele curso da
internet que a presença de graça e tem
mais de 500 mil alunos no mundo inteiro
todos os países e eu estava à frente de
uma equipe de cem pessoas é recrutando e
liderando o pessoal pra conseguir trocar
o cft isso pro e isso é uma experiência
fenomenal pra mim e meio que culminou
neste dia aí tá uma foto do secif lá em
harvard e culminou no dia que deve mesmo
que aquele cara que tá ali me chamou
para subir neste palco na frente de mil
alunos
lá em harvard contando a minha história
o concurso que tinha trazido aqui no
brasil para todo mundo mas agora que
levou rebobina a fita um pouquinho tá
bom é eu como falei só de vitória
estudei no ifes instituto federal de
educação do instituto federal do
espírito santo e eu fizer o técnico
integrado ao ensino médio e quando
estava no primeiro ano eu nunca tinha
pensado que podia estudar em harvard
era coisa para outras pessoas é coisa de
quem era muito rico e e quem lá além de
pensar nisso mas aí quando estava no
ensino médio 1º ano chegou menino pra
mim falou
gabriel é muito inteligente vai embora
vai para harvard e eu olhei pra ele foi
sabe que eu nunca tinha pensado nisso eu
tinha notas ok eu consegui ir bem nas
provas e tal mas eu não ligava muito
negócio de nota eu sei que cheguei
naquele dia em casa e pesquisei e vi que
eu poderia tentar aplicar para a
faculdade como harvard como ética e eu e
naquele dia com 14 anos eu botei na
cabeça que era isso que eu queria
junto com a carol de novo a minha irmã
que acabou de passar na universidade
dinheiro está indo pra lá e é importante
estar junto com ela porque naquele dia
duas coisas é mudar na minha vida
a primeira coisa foi sobre inglês eu
quero aprender mais inglês então eu
botei na cabeça que é só ler livros em
inglês e que eu ia falar só em inglês
com a irmã que a gente fala até hoje faz
17 anos ea segunda coisa é essa é muito
muito importante
é o negócio de fazer coisas diferentes e
houve quem passar na faculdade como
harvard e mit e é faziam sempre coisas
diferentes estão sempre atrás de de
criar uma coisa nova que os outros
alunos por perto não estava fazendo e
uma primeira coisa que eu fiz que eu vou
fazer porque eu vi que muita gente já
sabe aonde é matéria faculdade contava
numérico cálculo e física de engenharia
e tal
na minha área que eu sempre gostei muito
dele física e cálculo e matemática
engenharia mas eu percebo já tá eu já tô
jato atrás eu não sabia nada de limite
de derivado integral então fui lá eu com
14 anos batendo à porta o professor de
calculada do ifs então pôde assistir à
aula com o pessoal que era mais velho
pode ter problema nenhum e só que
calcula um é de manhã e com dois é a
tarde
eu estudava de manhã ensino médio então
não poderia fazer o cálculo era de manhã
então falei 'vamos local por dois e eu
vi ele literalmente não sabia nada disso
mas eu peguei um livrinho de cálculo um
anátema até que as primeiras duas
semanas não entendia nada que você está
falando mas fui lendo meu livrinho fui
aprendendo e ele no final das contas eu
consegui tirar a melhor nota da sala
nesse curso de cálculo com o pessoal que
tinha 20 21 22 anos e o professor acabou
me chamando para a monitoria depois pra
esse pessoal que era mais velha do que
eu estou muito legal foi uma das
primeiras experiências de de ensinar pra
mim e e que no final me ajudou muito
também depois quando fiz essa coisa dos
151 alguns anos depois mas pensa nessas
coisas e fazer diferente e começar isso
sempre foi muito importante pra mim e
depois não parei mais de fazer coisas
diferentes as pessoas hoje me perguntam
que gabriel como que vai estudar em
harvard e eu sempre falo para alguém que
está no ensino médio 1º 2º 3º ano e eu
falo que não entra nos acham que não tem
receita de bolo pra estudar em harvard e
mit aí uma faculdade itop assim mas eu
acho que tem receita de bronze
eu falo constrói um avião está no ensino
médio para encontrar o avião depois aí
que voa voa nele e depois fala conta lá
você gosta muito e devemos ter muita
paixão por isso eu tenho certeza vai
passando uma universidade muito top e ea
ideia disso aqui pra mim eu sempre
ficava esperando uma idéia grandiosa um
facebook
inventar o que as idéias são muito
importantes e hoje em dia eu acho que a
idéia não vale quase nada que o trabalho
vale muito a construir um avião dá muito
trabalho
é uma ideia besta porque milhares de
pessoas já fizeram um avião antes mas dá
muito trabalho e trabalho muito
reconhecido o trabalho leva as pessoas a
melhorar muito pra frente só que pra
você avião óbvio pode ser uma coisa que
voa mas também pode ser um curso de
computação também pode ser uma medalha
de basquete também pode ser pegar a lo
pegar 11 meninos que estão na rua e
botar ele pra estudar a melhor escola do
rio de janeiro o tempo todo na minha
trajetória eu sempre olhava pra quem
estava do meu lado e hoje em dia está
muito claro pra mim que muita gente fala
gabriel é muito inteligente é gênio de
computação sei o quê e na verdade na
verdade eu sempre as pessoas estavam
perto de mim por exemplo está fazendo
curso de cálculo e tinha cinco ou seis
alunos no meu estilo médica poderiam
estar fazendo aquele mesmo curso ficou
comigo estão tirando nota tão bom ou
melhor do que a minha sempre que a gente
com a mesma capacidade ou incapacidade
maior em termos de talento de matemática
de inglês quando coisas assim mas a
única diferença era que eu estava
fazendo e ninguém mais estava fazendo
então esse fazer sempre foi muito muito
importante e meio que por aí eu fui
aprendendo também que eu poderia tentar
fazer coisas mais e e em cada vez
maiores
é eu me envolver com uma equipe de
robótica bastante tempo no ensino médio
também já foi para o campeonato mundial
algumas vezes e uma vez a gente
conseguiu ganhar o a medalha de melhor
design do robô no campeonato mundial no
méxico e foi basicamente porque eu me
perguntei o que é o melhor algoritmo do
mundo em robótica atualmente a é o
pessoal usa lá no google naquele carro
que anda sozinho
aí eu fui atrás ao invés de pegar o
algoritmo mais base qualquer coisa lá eu
fui atrás de buscar o mais melhor do
mundo porque como é que vai ganhar o
campeonato mundial se não fosse atrás do
melhor do mundo e fomos atrás
implementar chamava filtro de partículas
slum e metal ea gente foi atrás
implementou um negócio ea gente
conseguiu
e então cada vez mais e e essencialmente
não dava tanto as pessoas estavam
tentando fazer agora é mais simples
porque eles não pensavam em fazer
o o melhor do mundo isso pra mim eu
sempre tentava puxar para si a pessoa
está pensando um pouco mais um pouco
maior
agora o brasil é uma coisa que eu eu me
orgulho muito do brasil eu sinto muita
muita responsabilidade e vontade de
construir um país cada vez melhor e para
mim o maior problema do brasil é de
longe a desigualdade
eu acho que ele tem todo mundo tá com
isso na cabeça e pensar sobre isso e
desigualdade
até eu não ia botar tudo isso na minha
palestra agora mas eu conversei com a
regina casé ali atrás e ela me pediu pra
eu falar alguma coisa
quem está começando aqui existe uma
palavra meritocracia que aqui no brasil
muitas vezes é levada meio com uma
conotação ruim eu fico muito triste ver
isso aqui pra mim meritocracia boa é
muito boa lá sozinhos por exemplo quando
se passa em harvard 1.600 pessoas dos
melhores alunos do mundo passo e aí não
tem se você é pobre ou rico você pode
pagar ou não
depois que todo mundo passou eles vão
perguntar seu imposto de renda e quem
pode pagar paga quem não pode pagar não
paga e paga tudo e você nem tem
ressarcir nunca entendeu e e quando
estão procurando a quem são as pessoas
boas não olham só para uma nota absoluta
eles olham muito para o delta a única
que chegou dadas as oportunidades que
você tinha eu acho isso muito importante
é eu acho que no brasil detém cada vez
mais caminhar para a meritocracia em
delta olhando pra figura inteira e não
só pra uma coisa tão boa quanto o número
de uma nota de uma prova e isso toca
muito na questão de oportunidade que o
problema da desigualdade a desigualdade
faz com que as pessoas não tenham as
mesmas oportunidades
tem gente tem muito mais oportunidade de
fazer um avião e outras pessoas mas eu
acredito muito que existe uma
oportunidade que todo brasileiro toda
pessoa no mundo têm a oportunidade de
impactar a própria comunidade
eu acho que todo mundo deveria tentar
levar isso para frente agora dando uma
um passo para trás como os americanos
sempre falam pensando muito na minha
história é errado nesses últimos três
anos
falta um ano ainda não acabou fazendo um
curso de mestrado
sem essa conclusão junto com a economia
mas foram os com certeza os três anos
mas dentro da minha vida eu fiz um curso
de matemática que é considerado o mais
difícil do mundo eu tive essa
experiência com o city trabalhando com
gestão e tecnologia que foi muito
importante pra mim eu tive oportunidade
de poder falar no ted ex do rio de
janeiro e é a coisa mais mais importante
que já deu pra mim na minha opinião é
essa idéia de que eu posso fazer
qualquer coisa que quiser que eu tenho
muita paixão muita vontade de ir atrás
disso e eu acho que isso não é uma coisa
só que os alunos de harvard o dinheiro
ou de marte tem uma coisa que todo mundo
tem mas que as pessoas não vão tanto
atrás
e pra finalizar eu queria voltar aquela
história de de sonho porque quando eu
tinha 14 anos
eu tenho um sonho na cabeça um sonho
grande que eu queria estudar em harvard
e desde então não parei mais de sonhar
meu sonho é grande hoje em dia é fazer
uma startup brasileira maior do que o
google amanhã embarcando pra pra
califórnia pra perceber esse sonho
a pessoa que eu mais admiro no mundo ela
sempre fala que só é grande não é
pequeno do mesmo trabalho
então vamos todo mundo está grande
obrigado